[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7 8 sociétés un numéro
consacré aux châtelains il existe 40
mille châteaux en france plus de la
moitié appartiennent à des propriétaires
privés
elle les châtelains dans les yvelines
comment font-ils vivre leur château
c'est le sujet du jour avec nous pour en
parler henri-françois de breteuil
marquis et propriétaire du château de
breteuil située à choisel bonjour face à
vous pascal thévard à directeur du
château de dampierre vous représentez
franky mulliez propriétaire du site
bonjour bonsoir merci à vous d'avoir
accepté mon invitation
revenons à la genèse de ces domaines
commençons avec vous marquis le château
de breteuil appartient à votre famille
depuis 400 ans mais n'est accessible au
public depuis seulement 50 ans et cela
est grâce à vous vous êtes initialement
avocat mais vous aviez déjà un attrait
pour l'histoire puisque vous avez été
lauréat du concours général des lycées
et collèges en histoire à 19 ans vous
vous engagez pour ce domaine alors que
votre père voulait le vendre c'est avec
votre mère que vous vous êtes battus
vous avez rencontré le ministre de la
culture de l'époque andré malvaux pour
classer ce domaine est de 19 ans ces
jeunes mais vous avez réussi à relever
ces défis
écoutez c'est vrai que ce château je
dirais que gelée dans la peau même avant
avoir 19 ans parce que je crois que très
jeune mais pour nous tout premier
souvenir j'avais 5 ans et curieusement
celui qui m'a initié au château qui m'a
appris beaucoup de choses pas d'ailleurs
curieusement parce que c'était un homme
exceptionnel
c'était l'ancien cuisinier château qui
avait connu beaucoup de monde qui l'a vu
fil passé à breteil notamment les rois
d'angleterre puisque trois rois
d'angleterre était venu à breteuil et
lui étaient tellement imbriquée dans ce
château que dès que j'étais jeune j'ai
toujours une idée qu'il fallait sauver
château et qui trônerait trouver des
moyens pour faire en sorte qu'il reste
dans la famille votre part ne vous en a
pas voulu de faire ce choix
au début oui mais mon père était
quelqu'un de très sincères cet état un
artiste musicien et il considérait que
c'était une catastrophe pour un jeune
homme à l'époque là j'avais
lui niveau du bac si vous voulez donc de
16 17 ans environ et il considère que
c'est une catastrophe pour un jeune
homme de s'investir dans un château
qu'il aurait mieux fait de devenir un
grand directeur que mon vis-à-vis à côté
de moi ou un grand administrateur comme
notre ami keith à chambord donc et il
était à la fois très inquiet il
considérait que j'avais un peu gâché ma
vie au vent et j'ai dû beaucoup résisté
parce qu'au fond mon père me disait
écoute moi j'ai 60 ans si on a 16 je
sais ce qui est bien pour toi et moi
j'avais plutôt tendance à dire j'ai 16
ans je sais ce qui est bien pour moi et
ce qui est bien pour moi surtout pour le
château qui était le garder dans la
famille et surtout bien sûr trouver des
moyens de pouvoir le garder et de
comment dire de l'animé d'une manière ou
d'une autre
autre histoire à présent celle du
domaine de dampierre propriété de la
famille de louis pendant 400 ans le
domaine appartient maintenant à franky
mulliez membre de la célèbre famille
d'entrepreneurs du même nom franky
mulliez surtout connu pour avoir fondé
kiloutou
et cette entreprise compte plus de 5000
salariés aujourd'hui
pascal thévard vous êtes le porte parole
de franky mulliez et directeur du
domaine de dampierre
comment un homme d'affaires a réussi ce
pari fou
et pourquoi ce risque est ce que c'est
vraiment un risque quand on a comme le
francky mulliez la passion pour les
monuments pour les belles choses pour
les belles oeuvres
et bien c'est pas un risque c'est tout
simplement un coup de coeur je crois
pour dampierre qu'il a eue quand il a
découvert ce site et dampierre il l'a
aimée non seulement pour le château mais
aussi pour son environnement
et c'est cette passion qu'il me demande
maintenant que le public découvre et
françois cau voilà qu est-ce qu
transmettre cette passion auprès du
public et pour franky mulliez c'est tout
naturellement que l'investissement qu'il
fait par passion pour dampierre pour lui
une sorte de reconnaissance vis-à-vis du
public qui a soutenu son initiative en
fondant kiloutou est donc aujourd'hui il
envie de rendre une part de tout ce
qu'il a gagné à travers dampierre et un
autre domaine existe dans les yvelines
thoiry il y a à 51 ans paul de la
panouse transformer le parc du château
de thoiry en parc animalier pour
permettre la survie de son château et de
son héritage familial en allant en
amenant ce zoo au début personne n'y
croyait
c'est pourtant devenu une affaire de
famille qu'elle est à vous votre idée
novatrice pour faire vivre vos domaines
eh bien je dirais que à breteil depuis
le le tout début donc il ya cinquante
ans vous avez les gentillesses de le
rappeler au fond on a voulu d'abord
parlé de l'histoire du château
car au fond et l'histoire très très
riche car beaucoup de bretons qui
achètent des bretelles de mes ancêtres
mais il ya celle de la france même ou de
l'angleterre d'autres pays qui ont
laissé beaucoup de d'emprunter 2 et de
traces dans ce château
donc au début on parle de l'histoire et
puis ensuite très vite on va s'occuper
des jardins ça se fera plaisir à notre
ami qui est un et spécialiste des
jardins et puis par la suite on a on est
à des encore un peu plus loin donc
l'histoire des jardins et ensuite les
contes de perrault parce qu'il y avait
un lien entre louis ii - teg était le
patron de peron quelque sorte et charles
perrault l'auteur des pontes et puis
pour justement faire vivre ce château on
a toujours beaucoup voulu avec mon
épouse qui a entrepris touche avec moi
on a toujours voulu vous soulignez le
rose des enfants il ya un visiteur sur
2 à bretelles qui est un enfant soit
venu avec les écoles soient venus en
famille sur les 140 milles de visiteurs
actuelle le canton a démarré nous avons
et le premier jour 12 8 heures ce qui
donne toujours des espoirs de bonté et à
dampierre à dampierre la dynamique de
développement et passe par les
animations des animations respectueuse
du site évidemment c'est c'est tout ce
que ce que l'on demande pour dampierre
et donc du coup nous notre grand
challenge c'est de faire redécouvrir
dans pierrot public parce que dampierre
ça faisait quelques années qu'ils
étaient oubliés avec il était plus
visité et donc aujourd'hui maintenant le
challenge chez restaurer le site d'une
part mais aussi le dynamiser pour le
rendre vivant parce qu'un patrimoine
sont des êtres vivants et donc vivant à
travers des promenades en calèche tirée
par des mules évidemment pour faire
découvrir la forêt pour faire découvrir
les jardins et tirer aussi là je rejoins
le marquis de breteuil en disant voilà
il faut commencer par l'histoire puisque
c'est la base de tout est donc dans
pierre nous on met l'accent sur cette
famille de l'huile sur la famille aussi
maintenant de la famille de lorraine qui
était avant les l'huile aussi qui était
important dans l'histoire de france
et puis tous les passages de ces rois et
des reines dans le xviiie siècle et
voilà c'est la dynamique sur laquelle on
pour l'instant on installe notre
stratégie et en créant des animations
spécifiques autour de ce thème à partir
de 2020 et le château n'est plus la
pièce principale a visité il ya aussi l
extérieur les jardins c'est tout aussi
important que vos domaines je pense que
les jardins c'est essentiel
bien entendu il ya plusieurs sortes de
jardin à breteil mais ce qu'il y à la
fois des jardins à la française
il y a également ce qu'on appelle le
jardin des princes où les princes de
galles aimait bien venir se promener
il y à de l'eau aussi avec des étangs
donc une variété d'ailleurs une petite
anecdote ah ben si vous le permettez sur
l'histoire de deux lots c'est que mon
grand père henri de bretaye qui était
parlementaire
vers 1880 appris que on allait faire
passer un train dans sa propriété
alors il a été un peu affolés de cela et
du coup son conseiller pour les jardins
monsieur duchesne vitré s'élève lui à
dit c'est très simple on va faire deux
étangs et quand les inspecteurs des
trains sont venus ils ont vu des revues
plus de la possibilité de passer parce
qu'on avait créé deux étangs qui existe
toujours aujourd'hui qui ont sauvé le
pas du parc en quelque sorte vous l'avez
rappelé c'est promenades en calèche
franky mulliez possède 25 carrosse est
un passionné d'art et surtout d'art
équestre vous proposez donc s'est baladé
également ses voiturettes électriques
il faut se renouveler pour attirer les
visiteurs et les faire revenir
comment faites-vous pour pour vous
recréez à dampierre j'allais dire c'est
assez simple puisque nous sommes en
pleine construction et l'a donc du coup
les premiers visiteurs on est assez
fiers d'avoir atteint les premiers 20000
puisque pour l'année 2010 n'était pas
évident c'est assez simple puisque en
fait comme on crée on a là on à la pâte
pour faire me grossir le gâteau donc via
pas de souci est par exemple vous parlez
des attelages et bien on à la
construction d'un
musée des attelages qui est programmée
donc pour les prochaines des prochains
mois donc ce musée va crée aussi une
dynamique sur la visite globale alors
vous parliez du jardin tout à l'heure et
les jardins c'est une pièce essentielle
pour quand c'est possible à avoir pour
un patrimoine puisque sa forme écrin aux
monuments et s'éteint c'est une autre
pièce c'est une extension du du
patrimoine qui est très importante parce
que généralement les fondateurs des
jardins on se sont inspirés voilà nous
par exemple voir le nôtre à dampierre
mais se sont inspirés du site se sont
inspirés des bâtiments et donc le public
quand il vient quand ils découvrent des
jardins que ce soit à breteuil ou
ailleurs et bien c'est fermé on comprend
les sens sont à l'essence du patrimoine
que nous visite à travers ses jardins
donc nous évidemment là on est en pleine
construction donc c'est le musée des
attelages chez les jardins qui vont être
restaurés donc la dynamique se lance
naturellement par tous ces
investissements
l'une des activités phares du château de
breteuil ce sont les contes de charles
perrault vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure quelles sont les autres
activités programmées viens je dirais
que il faut à breteuil c'est un peu
notre notre espoir notre thématique
il faut beaucoup de renouvellement met
d'ailleurs dampierre qui est notre
collègue aussi fait cela à sa manière
bien sûr chaque monument fait cela à sa
manière mais toujours avec cette
dynamique de renouvellement jetons nous
sommes tous bien d'accord là dessus et
je dirais qu à bretelles va parler des
des aventures à venir d'abord nous avons
régulièrement des spectacles une
quinzaine par an quelles peuvent être
les mousquetaires qui vont me mets pas
mimer reconstitué à un combat du célèbre
roman ça peut-être qui doute ou qui va
venir ça peut être d'autre
d'autres thèmes il y en aura une
quinzaine et puis à bretelles et puisque
vous rappeliez de l'histoire des contes
de perrault
ce qui plaît beaucoup à bretelles sont
les conteuses
qu'est-ce que nous avons des conteuses
en costume qui vont raconter trois
histoires de charles perrault soit au
public mais également aux enfants bien
sûr
parmi ces jeux publics aux enfants
souvent des petits de 3 ans 4 ans
viennent écouter la conteuse et sages
estiment que les contes de perrault
c'est a beaucoup contribué à sauver le
château
ça a marché vous êtes aujourd'hui à 120
mille visiteurs vous parlez est de plus
de 144 144e vous parlez de collègues et
confrères comment voyez vous cette
proximité entre vous vu que vous êtes
sur le même territoire
moi je le vois fin c'est pas on n'est
pas en ehpad et on n'est pas des
concurrents puisque on est forcément
dans le patrimoine
on apporte chacun autre histoire ce
qu'il faut c'est concret en vallée de
chevreuse une dynamique et que l'on tire
partie de cette richesse patrimoniale
donc c'est le but que
on a déjà évoqué quelquefois c'est
vraiment d'arriver à avoir cette
dynamique est une destination
touristique à part entière et cette
destination permettra à tous de
découvrir cette richesse patrimoniale de
mon point de vue en tout cas oui moi
j'ajouterai que dampierre
je vais aller sur les brisées de notre
ami mais il ne voudra pas est ce que
c'est pour dire des choses belles
exactes sur dampierre c'est que
dampierre c'est quand même un lieu où le
roi louis 15 et beaucoup venus ou madame
de pompadour est venu on raconte
d'ailleurs que quand le roi venait
eh bien c'était le roi qui servait le
duc de luynes pour bien montrer cet
attachement
ils connaissent par coeur plus rien lui
apprendre à la famille de dentiers remet
donc nous c'est la famille bretonne
qu'on va retrouver au sein de l'europe
de la france
l'histoire de l'empiré est également
magnifique
donc ça c'est une union je crois très
forte qu'on peut avoir entre en dehors
des jardins du tout ce que vous avez dit
une originalité de ddk neige notamment
qu' une chose très nouvelle pascal
thévard vous avez travaillé au château
de chambord vous mettez maintenant votre
expérience acquise là bas au profit du
château de dampierre fronty mulliez soit
il l'a même le même rayonnement au
château de dampierre aux fondus je pense
que oui je pense c'est un homme discret
mais je pense qu'il a envie que
dampierre rayonne et il a rayonné temps
pierre c'est ce que vous rappeliez
monsieur marc qui au xviiie siècle avec
l'avenue royale de
2 oui 15 madame enfin marie d'un disque
à la femme de week-ends aussi a passé
beaucoup de temps à dampierre mal de
pompadour aussi et donc du coup c'est un
rayonnement que dampierre à humer qui
s'est petit à petit effacés et donc oui
on veut rayonner c'est sûr mais on y va
en tout en respectant le patrimoine
wallace est ce vraiment la chose
essentielle qu'il faut pour préserver un
patrimoine comme celui-là le château de
dampierre a fait l'objet d'une
inscription au titre des monuments
historiques en 1928 le château de
breteuil et classée monument historique
depuis le 23 juillet 1973 on l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure en début d'émission vous
avez rencontré le ministre de la culture
de l'époque avec votre mère et votre
parc et ses jardins à la française et à
l'anglais sont labellisé jardin
remarquable
une question pourquoi ne pas avoir cédé
ces domaines à l'état monsieur de
breteil dont je crois que le but
notre but là c'est de garder dans les
familles et chaque famille à son destin
et sa grandeur donc que ce soit les
miniers ou les bouteilles est gardé dans
les familles donc c'est pas de donner à
l'état d'abord parce que l'état a des
choses magnifiques comme chambord dans
la parler mais l'état a beaucoup de
monuments sur les bras il ne peut pas
prendre tous les monuments transit il
n'a jamais été question qu'il prenne du
temps pierre mit breteil en revanche
l'état peut contribuer et c'était le cas
d'andré malraux à ce qu'un monument
reste dans une famille et évite
justement comme ce fut le cas chez nous
d'affreux promoteurs de venir se saisir
d'un monument pour en faire n'importe
quoi
alors là je dis que c'est ça c'est trop
de l'état de protéger mais pas du tout
d'acquérir parce que
je pense que vous êtes d'accord là
dessus de l'état n'est pas là pour on en
a de la chance une chance folle que des
springboks en breton et dampierre soient
restés dans les familles et maintenant
c'est une autre famille c'est d'autre
châtelain que je disais mais c'est une
famille qui est brillante aussi comme à
breteuil et tout ça finalement soufflé
lieu une réaction pascal terrasse je
rejoins tout à fait monsieur le marquis
de l'état n'a plus certainement les
moyens d'ailleurs de pouvoir acquérir
des monuments quand il le faisait le
faisait vraiment au bout du bout de
toutes les procédures que pouvait mener
les uns les autres pour sauver le
patrimoine et qu'il reste dans les mains
privées
je pense notamment par exemple dans le
nord à la villa cavrois la villa cavrois
qu'il devienne une norme château du des
années 20 fait par mallet stevens l'état
a attendu le vraiment que ce monument
soit dpf quasiment et à dorine pour dire
voilà on va faire quelque chose et donc
le pour le cas du domaine de dampierre
je pense pas que la famille de luynes et
eu l'ambition de le proposer à l'état et
que l'état a eu envie d'acheter pour
l'instant faute de moyens de l'état on
les connaît donc du coup cette famille
de l'huile a décidé de céder un français
et c'était sa volonté aussi pour pour
préciser les choses
2 que ce matin on reste dans les mains
d'un français donc france qui mulliez
bien tomber pour la famille de l'une
actuellement 1500 château sont en vente
à tous les prix pour la plupart à moins
d'un million d'euros et il n'y a pas que
le prix d'achat qui compte il faut
ajouter l'entretien et les travaux de
rénovation environ 1500 euros du mètre
carré et il y en a des mètres carrés
dans un château
c'est le cas actuellement du domaine de
dampierre après les jardins c'est au
tour de la façade du château d'être
rénové on le voit sur ces images vous
êtes en pleine rénovation
ça fait partie du jeu tous ces travaux
c'était quasiment obligatoire dans
l'état où le propriétaire a été acheté
par monsieur mulliez il fallait que les
travaux se fassent donc là c'est
quasiment la première semaine où les
échafaudages sont sont en place ça va
durer quand même pas de quatre mois pour
que restaurer tout ce patrimoine y
compris les jardins parce que les
jardins qui ont été un peu
agrémenté d'année dernière pour être
heureux il ya des études qui sont en
cours pour savoir qu'elle est à
restaurer aussi donc l'ensemble du site
devait être restauré la dernière grande
campagne de restauration daté du à peine
le milieu du 18e 19e siècle avec le duc
de luynes eux qui dans les années 40-50
du 19e avait mené cette grande campagne
depuis c'était nécessaire aujourd'hui de
refaire les mises aux normes mais aussi
les charpentes les couvertures et les
maçonneries le privilège de demeurer
dans ces gigantesques bâtisse à un prix
un grand investissement pour vous deux
êtes vous inquiet de l'avenir de vos
biens
messier de breteil moi je vous
répondrais que je ne suis pas inquiet il
veut mais je conçois qu'on puisse l'être
je ne suis pas inquiet parce que je
pense que ces monuments font il ya deux
manières de voir les choses
il ya la manière qui était celle que tu
es de dampierre bien avant il ya 50 ans
entend dire on ferme la grille les
grilles devant soi on être plus dans le
château et châteaux tombe
disons dans un état difficile et puis
une autre manière qui est de sauver le
château bas des animations l'ouverture
au public et caetera et je pense que on
peut donc sauvé des châteaux
et on peut pas sauver tous les châteaux
bien sûr il y aura de temps en temps des
problèmes qui existeront on peut
certainement site et vous en avez cité
un certain nombre 1500 avez vous dit
donc il faut pas nous il faut pas se
dire que tous les châteaux de francs
seront sauvés mais je pense que des
lieux comme d'empiré breteil sont quand
même à la pointe je dirais modestement
de la beauté de ce côté exceptionnel
avec une histoire quand même magnifique
et cetera desjardins tout ce qu'on a dit
moi je suis optimiste pour des deux
endroits et bretagne a failli être
vendus être laminée en quelque sorte
et puis nous en sommes sortis mais grâce
au public
et si on n'a pas de public ça ne
marchera pas évident et des opérations
comme le loto du patrimoine est ce que
ça peut être intéressant pour ces
domaines mais c'était alors moi pour le
domaine de dampierre en tout cas
monsieur mulliez lui a décidé d'investir
personnellement les 50 millions d'euros
de travaux
sur ce patrimoine est donc le saf
philosophie c'est de dire que lui il ne
demande pas de soutien public
même si c'est du loto du patrimoine une
subvention de miss à la culture parce
qu'il ya suffisamment de patrimoine qui
a besoin de subventions alors que lui
voilà ils n'avaient pas les décidé de
consacrer une grosse partie de sa
fortune dans cette restauration pour
sauver ce patrimoine
alors là après la question pour le loto
de quatre semaines peut-être plus
monsieur marc ici non non je pense que
stéphane bern a eu une très bonne idée
avec cette histoire ça wailly finalement
complètement ratée parce que un moment
donné me sers des finances a dit que
tout cet argent qui avaient été ramassés
par stéphane bern
il fallait les données sous forme
d'impôts à l'état ce qui était une
déviation total contre l'idée même du
loto et je prends à guînes extremis et
là je je crois que d'après ce que nous
savons ce serait le président de la
république lui-même qui aurait obtenu
finalement que l'argent du loto reste au
loto voilà mais ces objets sont quand
même des sommes relativement raisonnable
ils vont pas sauvé des grands monuments
en soi mais qui peuvent contribuer ils
ont surtout pour le petit dz des églises
et ça c'est une chose importante le
croit pour le patrimoine
vous avez des enfants allez-vous céder
la main oui je vous dirais que je vais
je vais céder la main je vous dirais que
je suis pas pressé
mais qu'il faut bien sûr s'il faisait
céder la main un beau jour en tous les
cas le problème c'est de savoir si les
enfants moi j'ai deux filles un garçon
est un garçon est ce qu'ils sont prêts à
donner c'est cet effort parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'efforts pour garder que c'est
tout moi par exemple j'ai j'accueille
moi même tous les visiteurs tous les
jours des vacances scolaires les
dimanches et c'est donc c'est ça
présente une et une présence et au moins
ça m'intéresse beaucoup plus de faire ça
que de partir en vacances si vous voulez
enfin je suis un peu bizarre vous avez
donc raison ne sera pas de même manière
j'ai pas si notre ami fragile devra
comme il le voudra et j'ai dit j'insiste
là dessus c'est que chaque château est
un cas un cas particulier spécial ce que
fera le directeur général de dampierre
il le fera à sa manière
avec son génie pardonnez moi mais comme
il a fait chambord etc
chacun doit
vouloir s'adapter au lieu au mieux que
l'on puisse mais on n'est pas on n'est
pas à copier et c'est cette mini vans et
tel cas là ce qu'on peut dire pour
résumer monsieur taylor le mot de la fin
nous fout dampierre la difficulté que
nous avons pendant les deux ans et de
maintenir l'ouverture au public sur un
château qui en pleine restauration qui
peut faire peur un devoir d échafaudages
donc on essaye d'agrémenter les
échafaudages avec des documents
d'archivés on va agrandir sur sur les
bâches et puis on essaie de dynamiser
pendant ce temps là la visite des
chantiers 17 jours un intérêt pour le
patrimoine nous parler du loto du
patrimoine c'est aussi la rencontre avec
les compagnons du tour de france qui
travaillent sur ces chantiers qui est
aussi important la transmission des
savoirs faire et donc nous nous allons
jouer là dessus pour que le public
puisse approcher la restauration d'un
patrimoine comme celui dampierre et
voilà ça fait partie aussi la sauvegarde
de tous ses savoir faire et de ce pas
tout le monde et je vous souhaite à tous
les deux encore de nombreux visiteurs
merci d'avoir accepté mon invitation
c'est la fin de ce sept huit sociétés
très belle soirée
mercher
[Musique]
nous